on est tous familiers avec la notion de
théories du complot la terre est plate
le 11 septembre et d'une simple mise en
scène mais les adeptes de ce type de
théorie il croit dur comme fer sur les
réseaux sociaux
plusieurs ont tourné ce phénomène en
dérision en créant au nom de l'humour
leur propre théorie du complot
suivi par des centaines de milliers
d'abeilles alors je rentre vraiment dans
l'univers des théories qu'on appelle ça
tire et nous nous indignons en quoi ça
consiste
c'est des théories qui ont été partagés
sur les réseaux sociaux vraiment à des
fins humoristiques mais qui ont attiré
beaucoup d'adeptes donc une des plus
connues
c'est la théorie comme quoi les girafes
n'existe pas et ce sur le réseau social
lui a dit qu'il ya 126 mille personnes
qui alimentent quotidiennement cette
théorie là puis au d'autre équivalent
qu'une qui est très connue c'est celle
que la finlande n'existe pas fernando
zones existent et c'est pas un vrai pays
est finie on retrouve aussi une autre
version comme quoi l'australie pourrait
payer le wyoming aux états unis n'est
pas un vrai que celle des théories comme
ça que les gens en fait on créé à des
fins humoristiques mais se prennent très
au sérieux quand on va voir ce groupe là
les gens agissent comme s'ils y croyait
vraiment donc une partie sérieux dans
tout ça dans la démarche mais mais
qu'est ce qu'on dit essentiellement
propos des girafes et des pays qui
n'existe pas quel est le cas
l'argumentation sa part d'y fixer des
dpi ou des animaux que la plupart des
gens m'ont jamais vu
donc ça permet un peu de dire voyez vous
n'avez pas vraiment de preuve que ça
existe donc pour la girafe
on peut l'admettre la girafe d'un animal
qui est quand même un peu hors de
l'ordinaire donc par exemple une des
images qui partager sur ce groupe l'oeil
sur la girafe dit que la licorne qui est
un cheval avec une corde
ça ça existe pas tout le monde est
d'accord là dessus mais la girafe qui
est un espèce d'hybride entre un léopard
signal chameau
commenter lorsqu'on peut les gens disent
en fait agir fc des robots c'est des
gens de drones qui ont été créés par le
gouvernement pour nous surveiller mais
est ce qu'on peut voir sur la forme
c'est que ce sont les mêmes codes qui
sont employés que ce soit une théorie du
complot réel entre guillemets et
s'attirer les mêmes codes
c'est ça donc les gens qui font vivre
ces théories la a juste comme les gens
qui croient vraiment sincèrement à
d'autres théories du complot donc par
exemple ils vont dire oui à des gens qui
connaissent la vérité il ya des gens qui
savent que la finlande existe pas mais
ces gens là ont peur de parler ces gens
là on les fait taire un autre argument
qui souvent utilisé pour justifier les
théories du complot c'est en fait il ya
des failles il nous montre que la
version officielle elle est pauvre est
et si froid et l'on peut les voir par
exemple pour la girafe une vraie photo
qui a été publiée quelques temps d'une
girafe albinos et les gens disent vous
voyez cette photo là c'est la preuve que
la girafe d'un animal qu'on le pain
artificiellement plana on voit là la
faille dans la théorie officielle des
gens vont créer aussi parfois des images
truquées par exemple on voit si dans ce
groupe le quelqu'un qui est en train de
peindre une girafe donc c'est une photo
truquée et les gens vont dire bon avant
n'a vu la faille ou encore une photo
d'une girafe un gros plan dit voyez si
on peut voir les boulons
les soudures c'est la preuve que c'est
un robot on dit aussi que beaucoup de
propagande que le gouvernement veut
faire la propagande pour faire avaler la
version officielle donc les gens
s'amusent beaucoup à partager les images
de jouets giraffe des livres de girafe
pour deux voiliers on essaye
d'endoctriner nos enfants 3
la version officielle pourrait leur
offrir un billet d'avion pour la
finlande pour aller visiter un zoo avec
des girafes loeb
excellente idée